all right summer is full is in full
swing and it is time for our celebrity
lifestyle expert
sema cohen to share her ultimate summer
essentials and must-haves
for the entire family check it out hello
las vegas now and happy summer everybody
i'm so excited to be back to share with
you my top essentials and must have
for the whole family all right first up
we have rowdy energy round energy offers
precise
time released caffeine and sugar
reduction ingredients
all with an amazing taste it offers a
natural blend of caffeine
from green tea and l-theanine to offset
cough injuries
rowdy offers five zero sugar flavors and
two
reduced sugar options i've got the
perfect summer snack to keep you
energized
and healthy core keto bars have all the
taste without
all the carbs perfect for summertime
snacking
core keto bars come in two decadent
flavors
including fudge double chocolate brownie
and chewy
chocolate chip peanut butter made with
100
plant-based ingredients they only have 3
grams of net carbs
and 0 grams of added sugar they will
keep you
feeling full while satisfying your sweet
tooth
what i love about them is that core has
a social
impact initiative donating 25 cases
of nutritional core bars to those who
need it most
when you tag egg whole foods and
at welfare on instagram you can find
them advanced pavilions and select
safeway and albertson stores
alright appleton's market power
veggie bites are made from locally
sourced
fresh vegetables quinoa and cage
free eggs they come in three delicious
flavors
thai sriracha sun-dried tomatoes basil
and mexican enchilada with around 100
calories in each serving appleton's
market power
power veggie bites are a good source of
protein
with 2 grams of natural fiber they're
grain
and dairy-free for convenience without
the compromise
and you can find them at appleton's
market dot com
all right last but not least
summer means being active and for the
parents with styleless
toddlers and active kids that climb on
the furniture
you need a solution to release all that
extra energy
we wilka creates high quality
handcrafted
and sustainable wooden toys that enhance
play and mortar skills in children
weworka is proud to be the first company
on the market
to provide specialized climbing
equipment
for families worldwide the new exclusive
worker collection is versatile for
indoors
and outdoors areas and brings the beauty
of
tropical mexican wood into your home
and you can find them at wilka.com
and the best part they ship nationwide
happy summer everybody there's